[Music]
joining me today is a new zealand-born
author speaker and founder and
headmistress of Michaela Community
School a free school established in
London all the way back in 2014
Katherine verbal saying welcome to the
Rubin report hi hi I'm very happy to
have you here oh thank you having me
I have heard a rumor that you sometimes
play my videos in your classrooms well I
don't know about the classrooms but
among stuff yeah among staff in the
school somewhere in the school yeah in
the school definitely we're all demands
thank you for our two controversial to
play in the class yeah I think so I
think so there's so much I want to talk
to you about about education your your
personal sort of political evolution all
the things that you've been through so I
always like finding out a little bit
about somebody's history at the top and
you come from a long line of teachers
and some interesting background stuff so
tell me a little bit about young
Katherine well um I mean my parents my
father is Indian Guyanese my mum is
drank and black Jamaican I say that
because the whole race thing is
important you know bizarrely because
these days you know people are so much
more interested in who said it as
opposed to what is being said and you
know some what some random person set up
a Wikipedia page for me and there was
this kind of major argument going on
between my detractors and and the people
who support me people who support me one
of the truth to be there the people who
didn't like me wanted it too wanted me
to be Indian rather than black because
black was kind of a bigger victim to
discredit me they needed to push me up
the the victim pole you know yes so they
might hit hard following the oppression
Olympics yeah I know exactly and so you
know my mother was a nurse my father
taught at University and came from you
know dirt poverty in Guyana but is one
of those extraordinary people who made
something of himself through hard work
and I was born in New Zealand and then I
grew up in Canada and then I've now been
in London for you know nearly 30 years
and I went to Oxford University
and I've been a teacher ever since and I
was a very left-wing teacher a very
typical teacher in that way yeah and I
used to write a blog which was called to
miss with love based on the book and
film sir - sir with love you know Sidney
Poitier it was in the film and I wrote
this blog you know a few times a week
I'd go home and write about how little
Johnny had his money stolen and that
kind of thing things that made me really
upset about the education system and
wait let's pause for a second before you
get to get to the point where you sort
of woke up and got in trouble and I'll
have people fighting on your Wikipedia
page so what what sort of education did
you have that pushed you towards leftism
or was it just just how it was kind of
like where do those ideas come from do
that did that come from school yeah that
come from family was it I suppose my
family yeah you know it's really
interesting because I think ethnic
minorities really are small see
conservative naturally but because the
black vote normally goes to the left my
family was no different from from a
typical family you know ethnic family in
that sense and so I was brought up in a
left-wing household yeah why do you
think they generally vote small to see
conservative or that bit why not vote
why do they internally either think it
or have been taught to thank you I think
they come from small see conservative
background so when I say that just the
belief in and pulling yourself up from
your own boots but your own bootstraps
hard work will get you somewhere
personal responsibility being stoical
when things are difficult but the kind
of thing that makes people successful
yeah exactly and and I think minorities
especially the ones who've been
immigrants moved somewhere knew they
believe in giving their children a
better life and in working hard in order
to be able to do so so it fits with them
okay so now so you come from a small
seed conservative family what kind of
voting left yes
and then that's right you start right
and I'm a teacher so everyone I know is
on the Left and I don't speak to any
conservative people because that's how
it is there's this big divide and nobody
ever speaks to each other I didn't know
any conservative people or the way
conservative people thought and then I
was writing this blog and that's where I
started meeting
conservative people and I say meat on my
blog so Twitter didn't exist in those
days people would have discussions on
the blog comment section and all these
left wingers would come on and start
attacking me and telling me how awful I
was with the stories that I was writing
and how could I judge the education
system as I was judging it and all these
conservatives would come on and defend
me and I'd be saying to the left wingers
no no I wanted well I'm one of you who
you know I'm with you I'm a good person
and they'd say no you're a right winger
and I think well of course I'm not on
the right of course I'm not conservative
I'm a good person
so how did I possibly be conservative
and the Conservatives would come on and
say I think you'll find that you are and
over years of me writing and me
insisting that I was on the Left I came
to realize that I wasn't my instincts
the things that I valued the values it
was that those basic values of personal
responsibility and and and and and
perseverance and and and being happy
with competition and all that kind of
stuff I liked and then I realized I came
to realize slowly and and then I met a
few people so like I met you would be
interested because you always interested
in meeting people who don't think like
you yeah I met this guy so there was
this guy used to come onto my blog
called
he British national party member so he
was he was just I mean people call it
the fascist party you know and in the
day they had a lot more power than they
do nowadays and so he was part of the
BNP and I would let him come on my blog
so all of these kind of lefties were
outraged how can you let him come on
your blog you need to ban him but I
always thought what do you mean can't
worry about just just comment it's a
common dangerous con he would comment
and get into discussions sometimes of me
and sometimes with other people and some
of the left wingers would refuse to talk
to him at all you know and they get
really angry with me but you didn't take
that I should just say you're not
allowed to be on here and then you know
I
he was on there for a just this is over
years and then and then I said you know
it'd be really interesting to meet you
because you're very different from
anybody I know and so I met this guy and
you know I mean he was a racist you know
I mean he was you know the things that
he believed about
black people and so on he was a racist
but you know what I always say is some
of my best friends are racist you know
it's like Avenue Q you know the the
musical with you know everyone's a
little bit racist and people are racist
on different levels you know sometimes
you're really racist sometimes just a
little bit racist anyway I met with him
he was wearing a suit he's a young white
guy um wearing a suit nice shoes and and
he went he took me for lunch he paid
from lunch
so the racist took you for life that's
right that's right that's what's so
interesting about life right yeah and um
so we went for lunch and he was hobbling
along and I said you know you were right
he said oh you know the thing is I
bought this Sutan and these shoes
because I was meeting with you and you
know you went to Oxford University and I
figured I gotta get dressed up you know
but the shoes are new and they're really
hurting my feet and I thought isn't that
interesting here's this racist yeah who
was taking me for lunch who's wearing
new shoes that he's bought because I've
been to Oxford you know and that's
what's so interesting about life is that
it's not as easy as some of the left put
people you know you're a racist you're
not a racist you're a good person you're
a bad person you're this it's not like
that
there's a whole variety of different
ways of seeing people and learning from
people yeah and um and was he able to
learn from you after that well we met a
second time and you know I mean when I
say he was right I mean like he was
telling me about how that morning he'd
been to see his girlfriend and they have
a toddler and he'd gone to see her and
see the the the baby she wouldn't let
him hold the baby because she knew that
he was coming to see me and she said
you're gonna contaminate him that's true
racism is that's like truly exactly yeah
exactly um but you know he was a good
guy in so many other ways and that's
what that's what's interesting about
life is what I'd say is that nobody's
perfect and people changed their minds
you know I think about my parents who
lived in the same house for 46 years in
Toronto and there was a man called mr.
snow who lived opposite them and when he
moved when they moved into the area it
was all white and he was outraged
because he was a racist
and he thought no way I don't want these
people living there and over the years
over the 46 years they got to know each
other and they became friends and in the
end mr. snows wife you know she she got
cancer and she died and mr. snow I had
to depend on my parents for a whole lot
of help and and my parents loved mr.
snow and mr. snow loved them you know
things can change people can change and
when mr. snow died my parents moved
house because the the community they
lived in and had had died with mr. snow
and this was a man who was so racist he
didn't want them to live there you know
isn't it personally powerful too I mean
I can feel it when you're saying it that
when you can accept some people for all
their flaws that it actually allows you
to figure out how to grow instead of
just other member ever even even if they
might do that to a whole set of people
for awful reasons yeah well and they can
change
I mean people change their minds you
know I have this quote in my office from
Muhammad Ali that says you know if a man
at 40 still thinks the same way as when
he was 20 then he's lost 20 years of his
life you know and thank God we can
change I mean when I think about how I
used to think you know and how I think
now well that's what life's all about
right so okay so let's back up to some
of those ideas because so you were you
were a lefty and then you started
teaching in inner-city schools that's
right that's when you started waking up
and that's what sort of forced you to or
of course you were led you to write the
blog yeah what were some of the ideas
that you were seeing specifically that
you realize wow this is not working in
these schools yeah yeah so so one of the
big things that I used to think before
going into teaching and everyone used to
just accept was that black kids failed
at school because white teachers are
racist the system is racist the white
teachers are racist and that's why black
kids are failing a lot of teachers go
into teaching for racist purposes now
you think well this is what's so crazy I
was thinking but I've met hundreds
thousands of teachers not one of them
has ever said to me I'm a racist and I
want to stop black kids from from
succeeding in fact they are killing
themselves you know working all hours
giving everything that they can to the
job
and I started to question the kinds of
things that the the normal the normal
way of seeing things was what I was
being told and it wasn't just that you
know in which we might get into later
about teaching methods and about
discipline and so on the kinds of
leaders I worked in the whole second
half gonna be on your solution okay so
yeah I started to question all of that
and I went there was this black
achievement kind of conference that used
to happen once a year which was about
improving black achievement and how what
do we do raising black achievement and
there was a labor so that's our left
political party black woman MP so one of
our politicians who used to run this
thing and I went along and I took one of
the white teachers who I worked with and
he was older than me he's retired now
and he'd been doing this for 25 years
and given everything to the job and I
took him along and these people were
standing up on stage essentially saying
that white teachers were racist and I
was so embarrassed I was so humiliated
that I had taken this man giving up his
Saturday to go and sit and be told that
he's a racist when he had given
everything to these black boys so we
worked in this boys school and it was
mainly black boys in this school and and
I was just I was mortified so gradually
I started to change my mind on these
sorts of things and then I started to
see that there was it had to do with our
expectations of kids it had to do with
our our expectations of parents it had
to do with the kinds of values that the
way we were giving them so if we were
saying to them poor you you're a victim
life is so difficult you're black you'll
never be able to get anywhere then it's
quite hard for the black inner city boy
go oh well you know actually it's about
working hard it's about we always say at
school even when it's difficult
especially when it's difficult you do
what's right right and as opposed to
saying that's difficult I can't do it
right except before michaela that that
business of even when it's difficult
especially when it's difficult that that
value that that that business of
believing in hard work
I didn't see it so much and and we would
give kids excuses we would give kids
excuses to fail and I wouldn't do it in
my classroom and the kids behave for me
and the kids learned with me and of
course I'm not the only teacher was
doing that their teachers all over the
place and their own classrooms were
doing that what I what I wanted what did
the administration think of you because
it sounds like you know oh we've got you
and obviously as you said you weren't
the only one but we've got people
pushing against the very because that's
the fabric of what these schools
eventually become that it's not it's not
on them it's on the system that is
ruined people where they've even begun
yeah yeah and they're poor I mean I
don't suppose people realize what I was
saying you know I mean I'm you're
talking to kids privately do your own
thing and if kids are behaving for you
and you're getting good results and then
then the principal loves you you know
it just works and people don't know why
I don't even sure I realized why you
know you just you build up an experience
over years and you know what works with
the kids and how you get them on board
and how you show them that you're in
charge and and then you teach them
properly and they love you for it
do you realize that your political
evolution was happening at the exact
same time
because it was sort of very personal in
the classroom but then that you were
evolving yeah would have been in another
sense
oh it is for a lot of people i when
people come up to me on the street or
email me they're saying you know
something's happening at work I'm
dealing with this and now it's starting
to make me think differently about
politics or are used to always vote
Democrat but you know something happened
here my family we got in a conversation
and now I'm starting to think something
else is a little bit different well that
was the blog yes so it was the
Conservatives on my blog that I was
realizing I'm agreeing with you and I'm
not agreeing with the left wingers on
the blog and it was then that I just
thought well maybe I am just a
conservative I accepted it and then in
you know accepted the idea of being
conservative and then in 2010 I voted
conservative which was a major deal for
me
and it was funny because you know after
I did that I remember this is after I
ended up in the press and so on I was
speaking to a friend of mine
I said to her and she's Indian and I
said to her you know it will obviously
you've seen me the press and everything
and how I voted conservative and she
said well you know I have something to
tell you Catherine
I voted conservative too and that's the
thing people are doing this on the can
admit to it it's so crazy so I voted
conservative in May 2010 and then in
October 2010 I was invited to go to the
Conservative Party conference to to give
a speech yes and that's like a
convention you guys have conventions
here and um I was a teacher I never
really took much notice of political
things I mean I I didn't I was a bit
naive and a bit stupid to be honest and
anyway I went along and I gave this
speech which the audience really liked
and and then I ended up all over the
press yeah so this is the speech really
that changed everything that changed my
life yeah for the worse at the time I
mean I think now I can look back and say
it was for the better in many ways or
you know at least yeah I mean I every
cloud has a silver lining and my silver
lining has been has been a good one
because I've made it into the silver
lining but I could have been destroyed
by it quite easily I mean in the end I
ended up without a job I was told that I
would never get a job in the state
education ever again yeah could you just
lay out some of the things that you
talked about in the speech right so I
talked about black kids failing and that
I talked about I talked about that's not
expecting enough of kids and how we are
constantly making excuses for them and
how we label them with things like anger
management or you know dyslexia or all
these kind of labels that we give the
kids oh he can't possibly believe he's
he's got issues that's what we always
say they have we they have particular
needs and we have to meet their needs as
opposed to just expecting them to behave
everybody has different needs nobody we
can't expect anything of them and that's
just the norm it's the norm so I I
talked about all this I talked about
competition and how it was needed in
schools that kids need to feel as if
they're competing against somebody else
and so on they need to feel like they're
being inspired to work hard
as opposed to being indulged and
constantly let off the hook because well
it's not your fault
your parents are divorced it's not your
fault because you live on an estate and
your black and your mom is a single mom
and you can't possibly do your homework
I mean I don't understand you know like
and that was because over the years you
know I'd visited I'd worked for a summer
once in South Africa
I'd been to see schools in China and
Brazil and India and all of these
countries where the kids were far poorer
and yet they were walking five miles
getting to school and working really
hard so why was it that those kids could
do it and apparently our kids couldn't
do it you know so that was why I
questioned it and I said all of this
stuff at the conference and the
Conservatives liked what I said yeah cuz
nobody ever says this sort of thing and
then as I say it was out of a job and
then I thought what do I do
how does that happen so you give this
speech you're fired the next day well no
I resigned it again but it was just
untenable like yeah the press I was I
was everywhere
it was like one of those Hollywood films
I couldn't go outside my door because
they were pressed waiting outside to
talk to me yeah like I said
responsibilities a thing go get her this
is what's so crazy all I said was
ultimately I was saying that the
education system was broken and people
wouldn't have that and the thing is I do
feel it's like the emperor's new clothes
which is that everybody knows that
there's a problem with the education
system but nobody is willing to say it
and I got hundreds if not thousands of
emails from teachers all over the
country saying thank god someone said
something thank you for saying something
I won't tell you my name yeah I can't
tell you my name because I'll lose my
job because they're all terrified right
so so yeah so I am I then thought about
the private sector for a bit but then I
thought I love working with
disadvantaged kids I love working in the
inner city this is what I do this is
what I know not I'm not giving up so we
had just you've had charter schools in
America for a long time we it was only
in 2010 that free schools which are
charter schools started in you know
there was the possibility of setting one
up so I decided to set up my own school
and I got a group of people together and
then we started trying to set it up now
this was not easy
because I had a lot of people who hated
me yeah I mean I still have a lot of
people hate me except I do think the
number is probably reduced or at least
they've just left me alone actually I
don't know if the numbers reduced I
think they just leave me alone I think
at some point they see that you keep
going and you keep becoming successful
and then they'll always find someone new
to feed and to scare but it's like they
you know you mean like at some point
they're like wow yeah we haven't got her
yet that's it and then they run out
they're not into hard work really so
they kind of move on to an easier target
yeah I need these I am a more it's
harder now because because I have the
school and it's really hard although
they do try you know when we were trying
to set up the school I was used to say
gosh it's like we're like making nuclear
bombs I mean all we're doing is setting
up a school I mean we would we would we
would have parents evenings so first of
all I'd be out in the street handing out
flyers running into hairdressers and
saying does anybody have any children
who might want to go to the secondary
school and you know women would be
coming out of their hair dryers saying
ok I'll have one other one going into
churches and mosques and temples and all
sorts and then we would have a parents
evening once we had it in the pub and
all these parents were arriving our
detractors are outside picketing they've
got like posters that saying Tory
teacher all sorts of insults the
screaming obscenities at me calling me
names and we have to hire a bouncer
because we were so worried about the
possible violence and then when I was
talking to the parent these parents
finding out about a school that's it and
there were all poor parents from the
inner city right so you got all these
black bums black single moms sitting
there trying to find out about this new
school and all these white middle-class
people and when we say middle-class we
mean people with money you guys use it
as a working you are when we say
middle-class you you guys say
middle-class we mean working-class when
I say middle-class I mean well-off
people so these white you know
well-educated well-off people are have
infiltrated and are sitting amongst all
of these inner-city people who are
wanting to find out about the school and
when I'm talking they're standing up and
shouting abuse deliberately because
they're trying to disrupt kind of like
when you do stuff and like the shaking
pennies and guards
we're gonna talk about that because I
know you had a little criticism of the
way I dealt with one of the issues there
related to education we'll get to that
but yeah so but let's just focus on that
for a second what do you think it is
about the intentions of those people I
try not to judge people's intentions I
try to judge their actions but these
these working-class and and I know
you're not into identity politics but
they happen to be white which you're
illustrating here that they're the ones
that are attacking yeah black mothers
that are trying to take care of their
kids
what is it that these people what do you
think they really think what why do you
think they really are so invested in
keeping everything the way it was
they'll demand they'll say that they're
for helping these people all the time
then they'll look at a system that does
not help these people then someone comes
in and says I'm gonna help these people
and there's a track record of doing it
yeah
and they hate you and then yeah yeah
they do and so just so I'm clear these
are white well-off people right these
are people who are who have everything
none of them have been privately
educated right I think it's because they
believe in making people equal but the
state should make people equal as
opposed to giving people equality of
opportunity because I'm all about giving
people equality of opportunity I want to
make it so that schools are so good that
everybody has an equal chance of making
something of themselves and changing
their stars right that's what I want to
do yeah they don't like that they want
these people to continue being not not
being successful
and then there's kind of these these
white knights in shining armor can come
down and the state can provide you with
money and a free apartment and and all
sorts of things and then they can sit at
dinner parties and feel very good about
themselves because well you know I vote
on the left and I'm a very good person
if it works so they're not interested in
whether or not it works they're
interested in feeling good about
themselves and they're they genuinely
believe that the state is going to make
things better for these people and free
schools charter schools while they are
state schools they break up the
education system right so the unions
aren't as powerful anymore and they very
much believed in the power of the unions
and they want them to have their
collective bargaining and if too many
schools break out of the system and
break up the system then it devalues
that
of the unions so I think that they
convinced themselves that what they're
doing is right even though there are all
these poor mums wanting to find out
about another option for their child and
they're desperate and when I say
desperate I've had mothers crying you
know in front of me crying saying I
don't want my child to get knifed I
don't want I want my child to have a
decent education so that maybe he'll
have a chance to get to university I
just want him to be safe right and and
then people are and then what they'll do
is they'll deny that that that that's
the case that there are schools where
children aren't safe they'll deny they
just they just lie there just bold-faced
lies about the system so what other kind
of pushback did you get as you were
creating the school like what what is it
like to you ok you fill out some
paperwork I assume them and now you
tried it you talked to some people and
maybe you talked to some teachers that
like minded people the administrators
and things but what's that like to go I
got to find a building I got to find
funding oh that's right so it's a total
nightmare
I mean really whenever any group comes
to me and says we want to set up a
school I always say okay well dig deep
right because you're gonna have to get
every bit of energy you got to be able
to push to run this I mean it took us
three years and it took us three years
to find a building there were so many
people against us and as you were saying
earlier I just kept going I mean I kind
of had to keep going because otherwise I
was gonna be able to do the job that I
love so I had to and eventually we found
this building I mean so first you apply
you have to go for a interviews you know
the panel interviews and blah blah and
you get approved and then you're looking
for a building and oh it's just all the
nightmare but um eventually we got this
building which you know isn't the
greatest building and when I say it's
not great you know there's no grass
there are no trees there's no car park
for the staff there's just the old car
park which is used as a playground for
the kids which is tiny you know it isn't
ideal but I always say it's the people
inside the building that matter and
we've made a real go of it and and it
you know it's it's great it's it's it's
and and what is great but everybody
really is great and this is where
you know I'm really you know I feel
really optimistic is that we have five
to ten teachers from all over the world
to come and visit the school every
single day mainly from the UK but we get
Americans Canadians Australians New
Zealanders I mean and they come because
they've heard about us through social
media and they want to see what we do
and then we get loads of letters from
teachers from principals who say I've
taken these ideas and I've put them in
my school and it's really helped and
it's made things better for our kids so
I feel like we're not just having impact
in our school on our kids but on on kids
all over the world you know all right so
let's really focus on what you've done
with the Michaela school that you
started in 2014 there was a lot in in
the research that I was doing about
discipline really before you even get to
education so you guys do a bootcamp
before you get to teaching them anything
you're actually teaching them some
things P early about discipline and and
sort of how to live how to behave yeah
and that's because we believe if you
haven't taught them how to behave then
you can't give them a detention for it
because they don't know how and the
reason why they don't know how is
because we know that elsewhere they
haven't necessarily been taught they
haven't necessarily learned it at home
they certainly want to learnt it at
other schools and that's because our
expectations are really high and so we
teach them we have silence in the
corridors for instance so that's
something people come and they say why
do you have to be so extreme I'll tell
you why you have to be so extreme
because otherwise you've got kids
fighting in the corridors bashing each
other's heads against the wall some
schools where teachers are scared to
walk through the corridors because it's
such mayhem you have silence everybody
just moves really quickly to their
lessons you got change over that takes
maybe a minute and a half children
aren't losing loads of time from their
lessons I we say 59 minutes out of every
60 minutes in the lesson you got it at
Makayla and we're trying to catch them
up you know a lot of our kids come to us
for the reading age of a five-year-old
six-year-old when they are 11 years old
in fact I mean some of them aren't like
that
at some of them are Oxbridge material
and we'll go to Oxford a Cambridge and
some of them need real help so that they
don't leave school illiterate and a
numeron 20% of the kids in Britain leave
school literate and numerate
right 20 percent one out of five
kids now and that's functionally so it
looks like they can read but they can't
really read and this is happening across
the country and it's become normal to
expect that now none of our kids gonna
be in that position because we teach
them so and we teach them in an
environment where the children are able
to respect their teachers they love
their teachers they thanked them for
their lessons at the end of their
lessons they say good morning and good
afternoon and so on and things that you
would never imagine you know inner-city
kids you you you know if you have an ID
on your head what need to see kids are
like you imagine the boys walking with
their with the trousers down here in
that kind of way and and and girls
dressing in a way that isn't appropriate
at her school none of that exists so you
do have a dress code right well they
have a uniform the uniform and that's
normal in Britain everybody has a
uniform yeah but the thing is we
actually stick to the uniform so you go
elsewhere there the ties are down the
shirts are untagged they look like a
murse they walk like a gangster I'm
always saying to the kids I mean if they
start if they ever start barking like
that I say you look like a gangster you
need to stop that right and they get it
they say yeah yeah miss yeah yeah I get
it I get it and then they start doing it
because we talk about getting to the
best universities we want you to get the
Ivy League universities to get to
Russell Group universities in Britain
and we want you to have you know you aim
for the moon you land amongst the stars
that's why we think right and so they're
all really ambitious and they're all
working hard why anyone would be against
this as a concept
I don't know so when you hear push back
against that I guess it's that people
think it's like presumptuous or
something to imply that their parents
can't do it even if often the parents
are failing or or the parents just have
to work too hard and they don't have
time to do the things that you're doing
and I think then people think there's a
racial element to that so if you even
address that I actually think they have
a problem with it itself they don't like
the idea of us being in authority mmm
they don't like they think being an
authority means that we must be Nazis
I've been called not a Nazi many a time
which is a bit ironic when you think
that what the Nazis would have done to
somebody like me but
exactly so and they don't like the idea
of us being in authority and us being in
charge so one we're really key on
discipline but - we want the discipline
so that we can teach them properly and
this is where you're referring to what
you said yes I was watching you at the
Oxford Union and you said about how kids
need to be taught properly and I was and
you've said they need to be taught
critical thinking and take me to task
yeah yeah yeah the thing is is that you
can't teach critical thinking right
people are critical in their thinking or
independently minded or inquisitive when
they know lots about something and it's
only by knowing lots it's like a 10,000
hour thing you know you got Malcolm
Gladwell you got you know Steve Jobs you
got the Beatles you spend a lot of time
doing something you will get really good
at it and then you'll be able to break
the rules uh-huh but if you're trying to
break the rules right right away when
you don't know anything then you end up
with kids and this is it the public
don't realize just how bad things are
where kids don't know where Paris is you
know kids don't know in Britain who
Winston Churchill is you know they
genuinely they have no idea and that's
because nobody's taught them because
people are anti knowledge so the
grandfather select the hold knowledge
movement is is Edie Hirsch and he's an
American his most recent book is why
knowledge matters which I would
encourage all of your viewers to read
you know education is the most important
thing in any country right and and
that's one of reasons I'm so pleased to
be talking to you because people need to
realize you know you you you can have
all your arguments about free speech and
about about I don't know guns and about
whatever it is you want but if the
schools are not teaching children
properly then that is the end of any
country right and I am desperately
trying to shout as much as I can to tell
people too that we need to do something
and and we are doing something I mean
we're doing something and other people
we're not the only ones you know there
are other people who are doing things we
named mckaela mckaela after a woman who
died of cancer who I used to work
and she in her own classroom used to do
exactly this and there are teachers all
over America and all over Britain doing
this in their own classrooms we need we
need it to be more than that we need
entire school districts you know we need
people to get this point and when you
said about teaching critical thinking
it's a romantic view that comes from
Rousseau so 18th century philosopher
Rousseau and he said you know man is
born free but everywhere in Chains this
whole idea of you education makes you
less free this is what the the
progressives think and actually
self-control brings you freedom right
it's counterintuitive but actually order
and structure make you free they allow
you to pursue all those avenues of
knowledge basically because you have a
sort of Center exactly if you learn lots
about something then you're able to
apply that knowledge in different ways
so I mean as an example you know if you
take a math question that a primary
school kid might be given you know John
has 8 cents at the end of the day it's
one quarter of what he had at the
beginning of the day how much money did
he spend during the day now I think I
can do it and I don't I think you can
too I know I'm terrible at math but I do
I think you can do it is because you've
got short-term memory and long-term
memory and you've got a whole bunch of
math facts in your long-term memory that
you're able to draw out you're able to
go quarter no there's four of those in a
hole and then you're able to go four
times eight because I know my four times
table and then I can do subtraction so I
can take it to 24 yeah right now if
you're seven years old however if you
have to hold all those facts in your
working memory working memory can't do
it you have got to drill and practice
those a timetable facts for instance and
put them into your long-term memory and
put those fractions into your long-term
memory so that when somebody gives you
something more complex you can go bam
bam bam and bring it out and then you've
got the answer sadly what happens is
people say now what we need to do is
teach some complex problem
solving let's give them that mm-hmm
first you got to break it down what are
the bits underneath that you got to
build up from and that stuff is a bit
boring yeah and because it's boring and
isn't very romantic this ruse I was
talking about Rousseau so
Rousseau this idea that you you you you
bring it out of the child right so they
they have this phrase which says you
know the mind is not a vessel to be
filled but a spark to be ignited and it
all sounds really exciting and thrilling
right and that's the thing it's so
seductive it pulls everybody in but the
reality is that actually what you need
is a whole lot of facts and you're in
your memory there that you can then go
boom boom boom and apply now that
doesn't mean that you're just a parrot
and you just end up learning a whole
load of facts which you then can just
you know regurgitate you need to apply
them and you need to give children the
chance to apply them and have a class
discussion and we do paired work and so
on
often in more progressive places they'll
do group work
they'll put five kids for kids around a
table and they do group work and then
what happens is the teacher moves
amongst them as a facilitator of
learning as opposed to the teacher who's
driving the bus I always say the teacher
needs to sit in the bus and drive and
the kids get on the bus with you and go
the more progressive way you're there
just keeping them on task you do that
let me come and see you you do that but
they don't learn very much and then they
don't succeed and then we say it's
because they were black it's cuz they
were poor what we need to do is give
them welfare and then they'll be okay
because that will make them equal and my
point is no fix the education system
give them an education and then they'll
make themselves equal gosh this reminds
me of
so I mentioned I'm not that good at math
and I remember the day I haven't thought
about this in Crowley 15 I don't maybe
literally maybe 20 years I remember
being in sixth or seventh grade and we
were doing division for the first time
yes and I remember the teacher gave us
we had a quiz or something and I was
able to do it in my head and I so she
they had you know the the equation and I
just wrote the answer and she gave me a
I failed or I got a zero or something
even though I had all the answers right
she said you didn't show your work and I
and I remember saying her but I got all
the answers right and she said no no I
need to see how you do work now I didn't
know how to
do it that way but somehow I was able to
do it in my head and I remember thinking
that if that was all necessary to show
the work that at some point I would get
to a place where I would have to do it
but somehow I had figured out my little
trick first but because of the way she
kind of just failed me for it it
completely turned me off man I really
haven't thought of that in probably 20
years or something that's this total
sidebar altogether but I guess it just
goes to show that we all we all kind of
learn differently and you need teachers
that can kind of embrace the way you do
it a little bit rather than just jam it
down your throat
yeah well you use which is probably a
little bit of the progressive thing that
you don't like in a way yeah what I
would say is you remember that
particular incident and think that's all
it was but I guarantee you that had you
been taught properly in that classroom
you would have known her methods yeah
you would have known what to write down
you didn't know what to write down cuz
there was too much chaos in the
classroom you weren't listening
you were busy talking to your friend
because she let you talk because she
didn't have high enough standards for
behavior yeah well and that's it because
this is just standard this is just what
happens in all classrooms and then
people think you know it's mean to make
kids behave and after a while the thing
is is that remember there's more of them
than there is of us right so we're not
actually making them do anything they
want to behave we're just creating an
environment where they're able to do it
that's all now there's there's the
there's the 10% there's the 10% on the
outskirts that the detentions I saw and
keep them in line right but the vast
majority you need that tipping point
the vast majority buy into what we do
and if you come visit our school the
kids will say to you yeah it's super
strict and yeah we get detentions but
you know what I get a great education
yeah and that's what I want because I
want the opportunity to be able to
change my stars and if you believe that
if you believe in equality of
opportunity which sadly I think too many
people in education don't believe in
equality of opportunity if you do then
you want to provide an environment where
they're going to be able to do that and
and and that's what we do and and I and
I really hope those teachers who come
and visit us they're able to take from
that and and and and do something in
their schools yeah well first off I told
you before we started I'm gonna be in
the UK with Jordan Peterson for a couple
stops so I will do everything I can to
stop by and maybe I can get Jordan to
swing by wow yeah daughters Makayla by
the way so they're really deep powerful
powerful what about the type of kids you
you've mentioned that there's some
diversity and the type of kids that are
coming and how do you guys decide who
actually can can cut it and who can
afford it and other you know all that
well it's not up to us who comes to us
it's the local council that kind of send
kids to us so we gotta they decide well
it's a lottery and people apply and then
they get picked out of a hat literally
and then and then they come some of the
people you know some of the kids would
end up with us didn't even necessarily
want to be with us they just end up
being pushed towards us because that's
the way the system goes I mean frankly I
don't even understand the system but we
get a bunch of kids we got 120 kids in
every year so it's a pure lottery to get
to the school yeah and basically if they
don't win the lottery so to speak
they're just going to the public school
because at that point most likely the
parents can't afford a private school
right yeah yeah no definitely the
parents can't afford a private school
but there's no I mean you talk about it
as if we're different I mean like we're
just another school there's loads of
schools like us in that sense around I
mean we are a free school but yeah it
doesn't it's not like we're the free
school and then there's the local public
school there's loads there's lots of
schools and and parents will choose us
if they want to and as I say sometimes
we end up with with with kids because
the system is such that you have to
choose your top five schools and you
know if you chosen us fifth you probably
don't want to be with us but in the name
of fairness as the people have chosen as
fifth have just as much of a chance
getting it and as the people accent got
very American there I grew up in Canada
so you know but yeah so people who don't
want to come to us come to us and people
who do really want to come to us come to
us
and look you know I call myself the
dragon lady and I say you know what I'm
not gonna change and if you're happy to
put up with me these are the rules and
this is what we do so if we hear your
phone or if we see your phone we'll take
it and we will keep it for up to 16
weeks and that's the way that it is
you know these smart phones are killing
kids I wanted to get there yeah yeah
what do you make of that because it's a
it's a disaster and in 20 years people
are gonna know you know when I say it
now people say oh you're being extreme
you know some schools they actually have
these phones out in lessons lots of
schools they have them out in corridors
and in the yard and so on we have them
banned completely and I'm even trying to
get parents to take them away at home we
know we sell brick phones so your phone
that you can't access the internet so
that what we try and encourage parents
give them that you want to keep in touch
with a kid fine I understand but you
don't need to give them a smartphone
that and that accesses the Internet
you know Steve Jobs Bill Gates all of
those big guys in IT they don't give
their children phones until they're 15
they keep them away when Steve Jobs in
2010 and the iPad came out and he was
interviewed and they said what did you
think about what does he what are your
kids think about the iPad and he said I
don't know wouldn't give my kids the
iPad he they protect their children
meanwhile our parents have no idea
they're they're saving up for months but
give the kids this Christmas present and
it's it's it's like giving them heroin I
say it's like playing Russian roulette
you know who you give anybody access to
your child on this bone right any weirdo
out there knows where your child lives
knows where how they go to school knows
where they go to school knows who their
friends are they get in I mean I I don't
understand well the reason why people do
this is because they don't know and they
don't think about the dangers not just
with random people but also lovely girls
who get involved with the bad boys at
school
bad boys who might be criminals
elsewhere etc and they they quite like
them and they wouldn't otherwise known
them but oh you maybe he's gonna add me
on snapchat you know and this is the
kind of it's terrible what about just
for attention spans cuz I would imagine
you're dealing with a lot of that for
young people right now smash those dumb
snapchat as you just said exactly so you
know before when they used to watch you
know Dallas
dynasty and so on at least there was a
narrative arc that went like this and it
told a story and then something bad
happened and then it gets resolved and
so on never done happened anymore
you got like 20 second I went to the
hairdresser's look at this man's bald
head and there's a little ditty that's
what they're watching right right it's
terrible so smartphones are a huge
problem for the inner city and but the
biggest problem I would say our
progressive teaching methods that have
infiltrated our schools and sadly this
kind of reso an idea that you're drawing
something out of the child as opposed to
putting something in and the way in
which over the last 50 years we have
turned away from knowledge as being
really important this hits of course the
most vulnerable so working-class kids in
our country you know that tends to be a
black thing in this country in our
country you know in in Britain it will
be black kids but it'll also be white
working-class kids it'll be a variety of
different kids who get hit by this
because if you are from a richer
background your parents you know you sit
around the dinner table at night and you
have dinner and you talk about the
politics of the day and you learn about
different countries and and science and
all sorts of things just through talking
to your parents and to your parents
friends and your uncle and your aunt and
so on with kids whose parents are not
well educated they don't get that at
home so they're depending entirely on
the school to give them what they need
to be able to succeed and sadly because
schools are convinced about this idea of
this romance around thinking critically
and and and that's not to say we don't
want to thinking critically we do yeah
but you need to give them lots of stuff
to get them to that point right so when
I said that at Oxford Union about
teaching critical thinking it's not that
you don't believe in critical thinking
of course it's that you really that's
not that's not something to teach at
least at first it's that you have to
give them all the the breadth of
knowledge first and then they will learn
how to critically think about all the
claims issues fair enough I like exits
and criticism exactly
really and and and it's it's something
that we're just you're having to fight
all over the place and and it's that
idea of giving them that equality of
opportunity which is what I can't I keep
coming back to because I've many
instances where this doesn't work I mean
have there been kids that come through
and just for whatever reason this this
concept that you've built that you're
instilling in all these other students
it just does not work for them either
because of something about them or the
family or I've had to exclude a few
children for knives you know that is
something in the inner-city that's a
problem you know when we talk about
inner-city you know we've got kids
showing up you know young men showing up
on bikes with masks carrying knives
waiting to meet some of our kids you
know this this is the inner city so
there are some of those issues that can
take over you know but but that doesn't
mean that it hasn't worked it always
works the kids always learn more than
they've ever learned anywhere else the
kids always are stunned by their own
intelligence and what is possible
because we show that to them and it's um
you know and what kind of breaks my
heart is that even those who are
conservative so you have oh I watch all
your programs and you have all these
great people to come on but nobody ever
talks about education you Larry elder
for instance who I love and I think he's
brilliant yeah you know he talks about
all these things play in the black
community and he has all this stats that
he always comes out with and there's
that thing where he takes you apart you
know he's not my real moments yeah yeah
but what but what he doesn't do he took
some absent fathers she talks about
crime talks about drugs and some but
they never talk about education and the
thing is education that's not black
people's fault right that isn't that
that is where the state right and the
state needs to be held to account for
this because we spend in Britain eighty
billion pounds a year on the state this
education system and yet we are failing
all of our kids and that isn't right we
and and Larry elder and all of these
people who talk they need to be able to
say no wait a minute
there's something going wrong at a very
low level because you can you can talk
all you want about personal
responsibility but if you haven't got an
education it's very hard to make
anything of your life so is the problem
then
that in at least in the American context
the answer always is throw more money at
it so it's not the real answer which
obviously we've spent 45 minutes talking
about which is Hawaii and how you have
to clean up these schools but the easy
answer is always throw more money at it
if they just need more money you know
you always hear these things well they
don't have enough pencils and they don't
have enough you know other supplies and
notebooks and things and people don't
take the next step which would be the
critical thinking step of the whole
thing not about money you could throw
money at anything yeah the irony is they
all go on about critical thinking
they're not doing any critical thinking
you know if only they would but um I I
wish we'll look I mean the the left
really refused they refused to recognize
as even a problem the right will
recognize that there's a problem but
they don't talk about it so so I'm
saying about the people who you
interview and so on I just wish more
people would say actually the solution
is in education because it really is the
the black community for instance you
know would would transform if they were
given the opportunity to have a great
education and and that's not to say that
all the things that Larry Alda talks
about about absent fathers and so on
aren't a problem right I mean they are
absolutely but it's really important to
call them out on it and it's really
important to call out you see and this
is where I would disagree you know I
consider myself a conservative and a
black conservative but I would disagree
with some of the black conservatives out
there who refused to recognize racism as
a problem at all you know they kind of
just dismiss it and I would say no it is
a big problem and the reason it's a big
problem is because the left in so many
ways are racist you know when they want
to own us and they want to tell us how
we can vote and they want to tell us how
we can think that is racism and when
they refuse to recognize what works in
education that's gonna help poor kids
black kids you know white working-class
kids in Britain when they refuse to look
at that well that's racist and I'd say
it's racist against the white
working-class the way the white
working-class are spoken about in
Britain is the way that sometimes black
kitni the black communities have spoken
about in America which is like there's
some kind of different they're aliens or
well you know that's just the way they
are no that's not the way they are
actually if you give them the
opportunity but you all want to sit
around dinner parties and talk about how
kind you are and how great you are cuz
your virtue signaling and
voting on the left you know and I just
wish I suppose that there were more
conservatives who were speaking out
about this and saying something yeah I
guess there's a weird reflex for them
where they've been called racist for so
long even though often they are
minorities yeah where they don't want I
see this I definitely see this yeah
where they don't want to use the same
tactic so what you just said right there
is such a flip on the way we think of
racism I tend to agree with that line of
thinking obviously yeah the people that
are screaming about racism are all the
time now are the people who are who are
racist they really are and I don't
necessary I don't say that lightly
because I don't like calling people Isis
but they are the ones who are demanding
and I look at everyone based on race and
sexuality in the rest of this now we
have to call it out but I think there's
a hesitancy from at least from sort of
where I sit cuz I don't want to become
what they became but no but I know I
know you're right at the at the core of
this look I understand you don't want to
say everything is racist but when there
is real racism you need to point it out
and you know the fact is that the fact
is that if we don't call it out all of
these kids are going to keep failing
right what we don't realize is that all
these kids are going through school and
are being taught to make sure that
they're going off and voting on the left
that's how it is like that that is that
that's how everyone thinks like it's
it's so standard in the education system
to think on the left that the few
conservative teachers that there are out
there they're quiet they never say
anything because they're terrified right
there is no balance of thought and and
and that's really scary I think and and
for the future of our countries we we
need people to talk to each other the
stuff that you're always talking about
about talking to each other and sharing
ideas and thinking about how the other
the other side thinks and and I worry
that we don't we don't do enough of that
we don't do enough at school that's for
sure and then those kids turn into
adults eventually don't they and then
and then we just
you know well I don't and then they're
really pissed at the system that they
believes failed them and then they just
perpetuate that through the next
generation too and then eventually
that's unsustainable actually because
then you have enough people that are
turning against the system that's failed
them yes it's because no one stood up
and did what you're doing but it's
interesting because this is where a good
old American classical liberal and I
know you guys at least in the UK have a
better understanding of what classical
liberalism I think that we do here we
talk about this a little bit before I am
getting muddled and mangled and all that
but this is a place where to me where
the government should be involved I'm
all for using tax dollars yeah to do the
things you're talking about where some
might think there are plenty of people
that are American conservatives at least
that want to just cut funding from all
of these things and endlessly cut
funding as I said I'm not for throwing
money at them just because let that's
just the easy answer but yeah let's
figure out how do we wisely use money to
empower these teachers and that sounds
like that's exactly what you're doing
well exactly
it's you know it's the power of bad
ideas at the moment that over the last
50 years you know 60 70 years ago the
schools that were out there were were
more like our school now it's just that
things have changed so radically where
knowledge has been sidelined it's all
about skills people talk about skills
and drawing it out of the child like I
was saying and we've we've lost we've
lost the purpose of Education and we've
lost you know the ideas that we have
about perseverance even when it's
difficult especially when it's difficult
personal responsibility you know if you
didn't bring in your homework then you
are responsible for that
whereas elsewhere they'll say oh well
it's not your fault you come from a
difficult family difficult background
we're gonna give you an excuse and if
you're constantly being given those
excuses and if later on getting into
university there are quotas and if
you're likely to get in because you're
black or you're you know there's they're
there things allow you
oh I took that box I took that box I'm
gonna be able to get in with a lower
score then you stop setting those
standards for yourself right and then we
don't we eventually degrade the whole
system because if you
someone in at a lower level and then
also let them get a job at a lower level
or get into grad school at a lower level
on the job at a lower level everything
else yeah well now whatever you've
created as a professional is a degraded
version of whatever that it's supposed
to be that's right that's right and and
that is what's happening sadly there's a
whole campaign at the moment in Britain
for this to happen with Oxford and
Cambridge University to to essentially
allow kids I mean it's just it's it's
it's really sad and what the reason why
is because they say hey look there
aren't that many black kids at Oxford
and Cambridge we need to fix this we do
I agree we need to fix it so we need to
fix the education system we need to fix
our schools and make sure that they're
given that polity of opportunity well
I'll tell you that day that I spent at
Oxford was such an absolute joy in
talking to so many kids just in the
streets and just and everybody was so
like excited to learn and yeah obviously
they were sympathetic to a lot of the
things that I talked about and and all
that I'm curious so I get it sort of on
the sciences and math and that you
really want to teach them the facts on
this stuff on things like history yeah
well are the facts in history no no
there are facts in history but I but I
wonder now these days where it seems
like young people are kind of into
socialism or young people are kind of
into communism or Marxism the rest of it
have you found that teaching history has
become oddly I was gonna say oddly
political I mean it of course it is
political but oddly politicized yeah so
like Hitler for instance has taught to
death but say the the atrocities of
communism and so on are not taught so
much or even then so rarely is so little
is tort . because they're not being
taught properly in the classroom because
you are facilitating learning and kids
are just teaching themselves I mean that
I can't stress how much of that is
actually going on so yes things are
politicized and children are not able to
access the kind of education that they
were able to access before and it's hard
because I'll say that and then people
will just deny that that's what's going
on but you can see by if you talk to you
know
kids at university and ask them what do
they know about the world and so on what
do they think they'll tell you and
you'll see how much they've been taught
what they've been taught at school so
few of them have an understanding of
communism and what it is and that's
because they're not learning it properly
at school school is sadly it's um it's I
wish that there was more diversity of
thought amongst teachers so one of the
reasons why we watch a lot of you the
Rubin report is because I want my staff
to try and think outside the box what I
always say is I can predict everything
that you think about every issue out
there so if I know that you definitely
voted remain as opposed to brexit with
regard to the european union for us or
if I know for sure that you would vote
for Corbin the the leader of the Labour
Party in Britain or if I know you know
what you would have to say about a whole
variety of different things even what
newspaper you read if I can make all
those predictions there's something
wrong because you know with me I'm
conservative on some issues but I'm i'm
anti guns for instance I'm pro-choice
and procane marriages all sorts of
things that I'm very much on the left on
there's other things that I'm more
conservative about you know and that's
because I'm a thinking person yeah yeah
classical liberal yeah I suppose in many
ways everyone might say that you know
I'm yeah the point is I just want people
to think outside the box right and I
wish teachers would and that there was
more diversity of thought and there is
some diversity of thought but they have
to keep quiet because they're terrified
how do you ensure that you get the right
teachers well in a way it's it's self
selecting so when they apply it they're
already people who are who are somewhat
thinking outside the box and then they
and then they come and I think being at
the school also changes their minds
about things they start to think
differently because they're seeing
what's possible people can't imagine
what's possible with inner-city kids
until they come to our school
I have visitors teachers who are
visitors they're nearly in tears they're
saying can't believe that these kids are
so nice so that's that's what we're
trying to do and the point
but and it happens here you know I've
been to sea so I said Edie Hirsch you
know some of the schools where they use
his materials and they place knowledge
at the heart of their curriculum I've
seen some of those schools in the Bronx
and in in in various big Queens and so
on and and they're doing a great job too
I just wished more of it was happening
and that we could we could get a bigger
platform to talk about it because it's
just so important but people don't
people don't get that they don't get
that starting to get it you think so
yeah I do I think that's why these types
of things are working that's why you're
half a world away you know thousands of
miles away and you've shown this the
conversations that we're having here to
your staff yeah the amount of people
that are showing up to these live events
amount of people that are downloading
these podcasts and all that it's
starting to happen mmm yeah well I hope
so I hope so I mean there's there's so
much to be had you know I've known tens
of thousands of kids people often say
why do I do what I do because I've known
tens of thousands of kids who could have
been so much more right who could have
been in a position to change their stars
and they weren't able to because the
state is spending so much money on their
education and isn't able to provide them
with a decent education and that's
really sad all right now one more for
you yeah I want you to offer so I know
that I have a lot of young people
obviously that listen to the show high
school sometimes junior high school but
college whatever else just for the
general young person out there that's
watching this that's in a school that's
not doing these things that's trying to
figure out how to learn and think
critically and get a good wide breadth
of knowledge but the situation that
they're in is not everything you've
offered here what would you say to them
to just start doing it for themselves
you got to take personal responsibility
so you can't be a victim
you know the whole victimhood thing is
just stoked all the time in schools and
and indulged you you've got to think it
doesn't matter where I am great I
haven't had the best luck right I would
have loved to be able to go to that
local private school but you know what
so what I'm gonna I'm gonna sit down and
I'm going to work and I'm gonna work
really hard and I'm going to
library and I'm gonna find the book so
I'm gonna teach myself if necessary and
I've known kids like this who have done
this I've known colleagues of mine and
people who I've known they just they
they make it their business to teach
themselves what they need to know and
they need to know that knowledge is at
the heart of it you need to know lots of
stuff and then you can manipulate that
stuff and then you can be intelligent
with that stuff right you can do it you
can the thing is is that it's rare that
a 15 year old takes it upon themselves
to do it bear it by definition they're
exceptional most kids need somebody to
guide them and if their parents aren't
doing it then I think the school
certainly can do it whether or not the
school should there are people will say
well it's not fair schools shouldn't
have to do that the parents should do
that and it's true and you know what if
if if welfare we're not as generous as
it is and so on the parents probably
would have more agency and
self-determination about themselves and
the incredible catch-22 yeah they would
take more responsibility and they would
do something and sadly the state hits
them in both ways right because it gives
them the heroine of welfare and then it
suppresses them by not giving them a
decent education and then they sit
around and they talk oh and they say oh
I'm a really good person because I
believe in giving people loads of
welfare and in having terrible education
I mean you know you punch somebody on
one side and you punch them on the other
side how on earth are they meant to
succeed right and the thing is we spend
a lot of money in tax to have a state
and I'm a classical liberal so I believe
in a small state but we do have a state
let's use it for what we can for them
for the good yeah but we're not doing
that and and that's what's that's what's
really scary and when we meet us all
believing in this idea of equality of
opportunity and that teaching children's
self-control will make them free and and
and having an ordered environment where
children can learn will enable them to
learn lots of stuff so that they can
then be motivated to do something with
their lives because they will make
themselves free bye-bye
robbing that opportunity and and and
it's that agency it's that sense of
self-determination that the
Conservatives people on the right right
leaning tend to believe in more as
opposed to mummy state coming in and
looking after it for you and taking care
of you because if that's all you aspire
to then what's the point of living right
but you know you have to teach dead
white men right like one of the big
goals we have is that they don't wanna
teach dead white men because they're
dead white men and that's a problem
right so they only want to teach
recently we had the situation where in
Manchester these students painted over a
mural of Kipling so red eared Kipling's
poem was up there and they painted it
over and put my Angelou poem by man my
Angelou now I'm a great fan of Maya
Angelou I think she's brilliant but one
of the reasons why she's a great writer
is because she read a lot of Kipling
when she read a lot in fact she's said
of Shakespeare that she thought when she
first read him that he must have been a
black woman because he would have note
he he had to be a black woman to have
understood the plight of black women
right because he speaks to the human
condition right but he's a dead white
male oh we don't to teach him Oh Kipling
he was a racist we don't want to teach
him but of our school we've got them
reciting you know the poem if if you can
keep your head when all about you are
losing theirs and blaming it on you you
know but at the end of it at the end of
it it says the earth is yours and
everything that's in it and what's more
you'll be a man my son and that you'll
be a man my son but what about the women
how can you not be recognizing the women
and in a day and age where men can be
women and women can be men he's
obviously seeking to me too yeah but
there's our rage oh no no no he's only
mentioned men right it's the most
beautiful poem our children learn it off
by heart right but children elsewhere
will never have access to Kipling now
everyone needs to has to be taught about
took the torch Shakespeare by law you
have to be taught Shakespeare but the
fact is we indulge in Shakespeare we
love Shakespeare because Shakespeare is
so beautiful and extraordinary
I'm just cuz he's a dead white guy well
does that mean that he didn't write
beautifully you know
there's just some beautiful I mean you
know love is not love which alters when
it alteration finds or bends with the
remover to remove it's also beautiful
and you want the children to be able to
access this and we teach them other
poems like Invictus which means an
unstoppable and when it was one of
Mandela's favorite poems and you know if
they say at the end I am the master of
my fate I am the captain of my soul and
all of our kids put their hands on here
when they say I am the master of my fate
and there's nearly 200 kids in the lunch
hole all this belting this out and
loving it because they are the masters
of their fate and it's teaching the kids
that and inspiring them to make a
difference with their lives whatever
their color as opposed to saying oh well
there's racism and sexism in the world
therefore you're never gonna be able to
succeed because then you just give up
and don't worry because there's welfare
so you can always just you know you can
just take the welfare instead of instead
of making something of your life you
know and that is what it is to kill a
man when you kill his self determination
and you kill his his agency and you kill
his motivation to do something with his
life
that is to kill a man and that is what
the left is doing and and I say that's
about that that is racism I do and and
we should say it out loud but we never
do the conservatives never call it and
they should call it what it is and you
know well what can you do you just got
to keep going right what a beautiful
ending that's an ending right there
we're gonna clip that one and do
something with that cuz I'm just perfect
this is what it's all about this is
everything that I'm trying to do here
you you're talking about the the roots
and the foundation of all that and
you're doing it and I promise you I will
make it to the school one of them Oh in
the UK forgot me great can I do a little
something to give a little talk maybe or
lovely we can do something this was
really a pleasure thank you so much I
hung it in and thanks to Douglas by the
way so we were used by Douglas Murray
yes yes now I know that anyone's a
friend of Douglas here for more on
Katherine follow her on Twitter it's at
miss underscore Snuffy
[Music]
you